in the environment of work how do we
address somebody who is not performing
we State the facts we recommend a course
of action that can help increase the
likelihood that they do it again in the
future and if that doesn't happen then
we say like this is what will happen as
a consequence neutral of you being good
or bad or this situation be good or bad
it's just these are these standards that
we will accept and you are beneath those
standards based on these facts that's it
like if you showed up to work late okay
just to be clear you understand that our
expectation is that you show up on time
yes I understand great you also
understand that that what you did was
not to that expectation cool so let's do
this do you have an alarm on your phone
yes do you use it no do you know how to
set an alarm on your phone yes great so
why don't we do this from here on out
let's set two alarms 5 minutes apart at
this time that'll give you ample time to
get up clean your face whatever and then
get on camera it's that work and then we
measure and if it doesn't happen again